the dog days of summer are almost here
and that of course has veterinarians
sending out warnings for a number of
different issues from the wind heat even
exercise in the pool or a lake that can
leave your dog's tail with a sprain
you're seeing a lot of animals in for
signs of upper respiratory blame it on
the wind says dr jamie ogenstein of
oasis animal hospital she's been
inundated with calls from pet owners and
their pooches dealing with the blustery
conditions and our summer heat it
doesn't take long for them to walk on
that hot concrete and burn their pads
test the pavement with the palm of your
hand before you let your dog walk on it
keep them hydrated and in the shade only
take them out early in the morning or
late in the evening and even then if
you're thinking about hiking be cautious
as the ground and rocks can also tear up
your dog's paths the dogs will get
overheated so fast
and
the altitude you have to worry about the
altitude for some animals if your dog's
got heart problems be careful with the
altitude if they can't wait to jump in
the pool or the lake for a dip ease them
into that as well this sweet yellow lab
named henry just recovered from what's
known as limber tail syndrome also known
as cold tail or swimmer's tail he spent
too much time wagging his tail swimming
in the pool suffered a sprain that was
painful to the touch don't just throw
them in let them you know swim around
for hours on end
let them work up to it and so basically
you're allowing those muscles to kind of
strengthen themselves up the ligaments
get stronger too
large working dogs hunting breeds
athletic dogs such as labs english
pointers and golden retrievers are
typically affected by swimmer's tail the
good news the tale improves with a
little rest and some anti-inflammatory
medications